Latin American Spanish.
Rewind a bit to the concept of complimentary distribution where different
allophones of a phoneme sharp in different contexts.
I used the word context to give you an indication of the surrounding phonemes.
The other sounds that surround that allophone the normal term for that is an
environment sounds don't exist on their own.
They exist in a specific environment.
Sometimes that environment changes the sound.
Here are some examples of complimentary distribution.
It's Spanish
embodies in Britannia and Korea in Granbury,
Tanya and Hispana.
Yan done no,
so we see three different allophones of a single phoneme en one,
one and one.
We can account for these allophones by discussing their environments.
We can say that occurs between an e and a p or between an e and a B.
We can say that the ng sound occurs between e and K or e and g and we see just
the plain end sound between any two vowels or at the beginning of a word or at
the end of a word.
This gives us some understanding of how and when to reproduce these allophones
in complementary distribution,
but then we can move on to make more concise generalizations using our
understanding of phonetics.
P and B are both bilabial plosives.
We can say that the phoneme and shows up as em before a bilabial plosive p as a
voiceless bilabial Plos it and be as a voiced by labial plosive.
Similarly,
Co and gut are both Vilar plosives.
We can say that n shows up as that sound before a Vilar plosive,
whether it's the voice to Vilar,
plosive gut or the voiceless cut and then it seems to show up as n anywhere
else.
So between bells or before or after silence.
In other words,
at the beginning or end of a word,
now that you've gained more intelligent appreciation for the environments where
the allophones of and show up in Spanish,
you can move to creating a rule that describes how one sound becomes another
sound in those environments.
So we can say that end becomes an m sound between a vowel and a bilabial
plosive.
We noticed that in our examples,
we would write such a rule like this and becomes em in the environment where it
is proceeded by a val and followed by a consonant with the features bilabial and
plosive,
which can be voiced or voiceless.
As we saw,
we look for other words where the phoneme and would show up between a vowel in a
bilabial plosive to check this rule.
What we'll find is that the rule holds,
but we'll also try to find counter examples that would force us to modify this
rule for the sake of accuracy.
One such counter example would be if the phoneme end ever shows up as an em
before a sound that is not a bilabial or a plosive unfortunately will eventually
run into examples that break the rule in just that way.
Aim Franzia seems to follow our rule except that the sound following the
allophone m of the phoneme and is not a bilabial implosive.
It's a lay Beal dental fricative.
So we need to find a way to strengthen our first notice that both fricatives and
plosives are obstructs,
meaning that you highly restrict the airflow when you make them.
Also,
both labial dentals and by labels are labels,
sounds so named because they involve the lips.
What if we broaden a rule a bit?
The rewritten rule would look like this and becomes an the environment where it
is proceeded by a val and followed by a label opstream.
There you have a strong rule that seems to apply throughout Spanish.
I hope you now have a better understanding of rules and environments and the
basics of phonology
general.